decisions
so your mic is doesn't seem to be on
you're right
so one of these knock-on effects that we
see is an unprecedented energy crisis
as you all know we have been working
very hard in the last months against the
Fallout of the energy on the energy
markets and we have made progress
we're cutting demand we have seen now
that we have been saving gas 15 percent
of the overall demand in September
we have been filling our gas storages we
are now at 92 percent
we have been intensively diversifying
away from Russia towards reliable
suppliers
and one figure shows that by now the
Russian share of imported pipeline gases
down to nine percent so more or less
two-thirds of the Russian supply has
been cut
and as you know we have been if you have
made possible for the member states to
channel windfall profits on energy
companies to vulnerable households and
companies
thanks to this common action we have
reached our first main goal and that was
to be better prepared to face this
winter
and on this basis we can now take
further steps towards a real energy
Union
two weeks ago before the informal Summit
I wrote a letter to the leaders
outlining the road map on the energy
field that we have
this roadmap includes element that we
have already put in motion
for example that we've said we will
negotiate with our reliable suppliers
like for example Norway about a price
corridor
but we also have other issues in this
roadmap that take more time to mature
and have been intensively discussed in
the last weeks and various energy
councils or Summits and as a result the
college could adopt today another set of
proposals and commissioner Simpson and
commissioner McGinnis will outline these
exceptional and temporary measures in a
moment
let me focus on the overall logic
we know that we are strong when we act
together
therefore the first
emphasis is that we make joint
purchasing in this proposal today
operational
we know that Europe's energy demand is
very large
so it is logical that instead of
outbidding each other
the member states and the energy
companies should leverage their joint
purchasing power
and for that we propose today legal pool
legal tools
for pooling energy demand at European
level
what we're doing we're also enabling
energy companies to set up a gas
purchase Consortium
so that they are together able to
purchase gas
and in that we include one mandatory one
binding element
that is that we say the aggregation of
demand will be mandatory for at least 15
percent of the volumes that are needed
to fill the storage
why that because we have seen by
experience this year
that it is the last 10 to 20 percent
when we fill the storages that are the
most expensive
these are typically volumes that are not
secured by long-term contracts
and this year we saw our companies
outbitting each other on these volumes
in the spot market and thus themselves
driving the prices up therefore we want
to be better prepared for the next
filling season that we want to join
forces and pool this European purchasing
power
very important in that we will of course
also involve our close neighbors like
the Western Balkan or the Eastern
partnership
the second element is saving we've been
speaking a lot about it as I said a lot
has been done in the Energy savings and
Energy Efficiency and it's a good sign
that we now have a minus of 15 of demand
that we achieved in September
the third element is solidarity
sharing
this is crucial to be prepared in case
of a full gas and electricity disruption
as you know we have the European supply
of security of Supply regulation
this is enforced in five years already
it requires member states to conclude
solidarity agreements with their
neighbors in a certain region
potentially we should have 40 of these
solidarity agreements we have only six
and this is not enough in the crisis of
this scope
so with this proposal today under one to
two we are proposing default rules
on solidarity that will apply in case of
emergency as long as there are no
bilateral solidarity agreements in place
we all know that European solidarity is
the very best insurance policy member
states can have in a crisis
but there's also a second element the
better we are organized the better we
can make use of all the work of the last
month in interconnectors in
infrastructure in LNG terminals or in
the storage it is also a matter of being
well organized Among Us 27.
so these were the first three points on
pooling
sharing and saving
now let me look at a fourth element that
is about prices
we need to tame the volatility and the
extreme price hikes on the main European
gas market that is the so-called ttf
The ttf Benchmark has been mainly
designed for pipeline gas
but we all know that this Market has
dramatically changed
uh it has
changed from pipeline initially to much
more LNG by now
so the ttf that we see today is no more
really reflecting the true market
situation
and therefore we will develop a
complementary LNG specific benchmark for
the next filling season
we have to bridge the time in between
between ttf now
and the complementary Benchmark we will
have for the next filling season
and therefore we are putting in place a
mechanism to limit
excessive gas prices if needed
here you might perhaps remember that uh
recall that we had in March a
communication where we were already
proposing
such a capping mechanism but at that
time the proposal was not mature we
couldn't find majorities but we have had
a lot of discussions
on that in the past months so there is
an increased understanding now between
the member states and our approach is
much more widely shared and therefore
hopeful that we can now progress on this
very critical issues
here today we're taking a two-step
approach
today we are setting out a number of
principles for this flexible or dynamic
capping mechanism
it should be flexible enough to ensure
security of supply for example it should
be high enough that the market is
functioning and the gas is flowing and
it should be wide enough that it is also
covering the other benchmarks we have in
the European Union
so as soon as the council agrees on
these principles we will then come we
will flesh it out we will come with all
the details in a not trivial approach to
make it operational
then there is a lot on intra day Spike
and in today's by color but this Merit
you will detail out very important very
technical so this is your expertise is
being asked
now finally let me touch upon two
important topics that are not in the one
to two
all I've said right now is the in the
one to two the two other topics are in
the communication
the first one is how to limit the impact
of gas prices
on the electricity price
you know this model it has been
introduced in Spain and Portugal where
it has reduced electricity prices
so we believe that it merits to be
considered for introduction at the EU
level
and we are looking right now into the
available data to find responses to one
or two questions that are still open but
as I said it merits really to look deep
into it and to see how we can make it
operational on the EU level
and my very last point
is about Investments
it's not so much the actual energy
situation but it is referring to the
knock-on effects on our impact on our
economy because of the high energy
prices
you know
um that we have introduced repower EU
perhaps it's important to keep in mind
that at the beginning of the war
when Putin started to weaponize gas and
this tactic was obvious for us
we decided to phase out completely of
Russian government at that time when we
had these discussions eight months ago
you might remember that we were saying
it will take us some years till 2027 or
2030 to manage that
well
um
it went much much faster as you could
see from the figures I was just
presenting so this process has been much
massively accelerated
if the current Trend persists that we
see diversifying away from Russian gas
and if we keep up our action also the
saving action we will have received at
least 65 billion cubic meter of gas gas
from other suppliers than Russia
and we will have saved 50 billion cubic
meters of gas till the end of the year
that's quite a sum
and we see that we have this year a
record deployment and delivery in the
renewable energies
so taking all this into account this
acceleration in the transition that we
see
I think we also the same acceleration in
our investment
in the cross-border infrastructure
and in Energy Efficiency and in
Renewables
and here comes repower EU into play
we have proposed it in May
since then things have changed
dramatically as I've just described
and therefore we will now carry out A
needs assessment for we power EU we will
assess what is necessary to boost this
clean energy transition
and how we can avoid fragmentation in
the single market so that these
investments in the clean energy
transition are available all over in the
European Union
this will then form the basis for
commission proposals to enhance the
Firepower of repower EU
tomorrow every present these proposals
to the European Parliament and then on
Thursday Friday to the leaders and with
that Eric I give the flow back to you
thank you very much president and I give
the flow immediately to commissioner
Simpson
and next Tuesday we will follow up with
energy ministers at the nhltd council
the European Union has been fighting the
energy crisis for a year as the crisis
has evolved we have responded together
protecting our people and businesses
directing revenues to support consumers
ensuring sufficient car storage reducing
demand and negotiating withhold and new
suppliers and these steps have helped to
bring prices down compared to the record
levels in August
but they are still high and the risk of
further price hikes and gas supply
disruption for this winter is real
president already has laid out very
clearly the context of today's proposals
and the remain elements let me go into
some more detail
first The Joint purchase of gas this is
a topic where the groundwork has already
been done in April we put in place the
natural platform and since then we have
created Five Regional task force to
better understand our gas needs and
infrastructure opportunities today we
are proposing the tools to make joint
purchasing possible and this is a No
Regret option uh spying together gives
us more leverage
on the other hand it is not easy to
implement uh gas is in the EU usually
bought by companies not member states
let alone the commission and we have
worked very closely with CBP vestager
and her team to find a solution that is
in line with the EU competition policy
and we propose a two-step approach first
we will aggregate the Demand only the
gas needs of the companies willing to
participate and the commission will
contract this procedure out to a service
provider who will collect the necessary
data via the attitude
following that
the companies can conclude their
contracts with their suppliers and they
can also form a gas purchasing
Consortium
and buy a gas together coordinating
volumes prices delivery points and times
and there is a mandatory element
as the aggregation has to cover an
amount of cash equivalent to 15 percent
of the storage filling requirements in
member states
and this is around 13.5 billion cubic
meters of gas
equivalent of the use of Greece Bulgaria
croatians Slovenia combined all this
joint consumption of Portugal Ireland
and Finland so it is a meaningful amount
that would be attractive to Sellers and
helpful in terms of refilling storage
the participating companies will be free
to Aggregate and purchase more than 15
percent
uh we are only setting the absolute
minimum but joint purchase alone will
not be enough to adjust the level of
prices we are seeing due to the Russian
manipulation and very tight Global
markets and we need a new price
Benchmark that better affects today's
marketality better than currently ttf
while ttf was a good proxy for the year
gas prices when we received large
amounts of Russian Pipeline gas this is
no longer that case now DTF price prices
are pushed up by infrastructure
bottlenecks and Regional Dynamics and we
have therefore tasks Acer to immediately
prepare a price assessment tool our
proposal grants them the necessary
powers to collect real-time information
on all daily LNG transactions based on
this they can establish a benchmark by
the end of the March and until then we
propose to create a market correction
mechanism that could be used to limit
prices when needed we envisage it in the
form of a ttf cup
a ceiling on the maximum value of the
DTF virtual trading point and more work
is needed in cooperation with the member
states to develop the details and me and
my services are already gone to complete
this work fast and with the right
safeguards if given the Mandate by the
council in addition aimed and the
accessible agility of your energy
derivatives Market and my rate I will
tell you more about this
as we make every effort to keep prices
particular predictable and gas flowing
to Europe we cannot
exclude a real Supply crisis with a
short shortage of gas and for this
solidarity and demand reduction already
in the worst case scenario all our
member states need to be supported by
their neighbors and countries with LNG
facilities solidarity rules will apply
automatically even if the member states
don't have a bilateral agreement in
place solidarity should be no
non-negotiable
in addition to households and other
protected consumers solidarity
obligation will now also apply to
critical gas fire power plants to avoid
an electricity crisis in case of an
emergency there will be an allocation
mechanism determining how gas is
distributed and at what price
it is also absolutely critical that we
continue to reduce our gas demand in
today's proposal we give the member
states more flexibility to do this and
continue work on other fronts for
example this Friday I will host this
International NH agency
um an event on helping our small and
medium-sized Enterprises through the
crisis and then I just savings and
efficiency can play a role on this
increasing our Energy Efficiency is also
a central tenet of the digitalization of
energy action plan that the commission
adopted today and many of the solutions
touched up on their are relevant to our
current situation smart meters
remotely control devices and Innovative
renewable Solutions all make energy more
affordable and accessible
as we fight the current crisis we are
laying for their foundations of a
cleaner and more modern Energy System
which will serve us well in the years
decades to come thank you
thank you very much commission Simpson
commissioner
thank you Eric thank you president and
Cadre good afternoon everyone just to
focus on the financial side of the
energy issues what we're doing today is
working on the Nexus between energy
markets and financial markets and as you
know my role as commissioner it has
Financial stability at its very heart so
the measures we propose and I will give
you details shortly are both targeted
and time limited and they're focusing on
easing the liquidity stress that some
energy companies have faced in meeting
their margin requirements and on
tackling the extreme price volatility on
energy derivative markets in doing this
we've worked really closely with our
regulations so asthma and National
regulators and sought their guidance as
to how we would do this mindful of the
need to address the liquidity issues but
clearly mindful of the need for
financial stability I want to thank our
finance ministers for their contribution
and indeed our work with the European
Parliament is Paramount to deliver so
first first I want to deal with the
trading side we're proposing a temporary
measure as part of the emergency
instrument a so-called intraday price
spike color now what this is about is
smoothing excessive volatility and price
spikes in gas and electricity derivative
markets
it is a price color that limits extreme
changes in a short period of time and in
that sense
it's not intending to prevent prices
from moving upwards or indeed downwards
but rather to ensure that these
movements are more incremental than what
we observed at some times over the past
months
EU trading venues for energy derivatives
we'll have to put such a tool in place
by the end of January under the control
of national and European Regulators but
in the interim period we will be asking
EU trading venues to set up intraday
volatility tools that would broadly
achieve the same result
my second point is around the issue of
collateral we know some energy Market
participants have experienced pressures
on liquidity because of higher margin
calls linked to Rising Energy prices
usually collateral is provided in the
form of cash
today we're adopting a delegated act
that expands the list of what these
companies can use as collateral and
we're doing this on a temporary basis
energy firms will be allowed to use on
collateralized Bank guarantees
and all Market participants will be
allowed to use public guarantees again
we're following the advice of asthma on
this and striking the right balance
between helping energy operators and
maintaining Financial stability
the third measure is also related to
energy derivatives markets and this is
an amendment to another
um delegated act for energy firms using
otc's over-the-counter energy
derivatives we're raising the carrying
threshold from 3 billion today to 4
billion euros and below this 4 billion
year threshold firms using
over-the-counter derivatives will not
have to provide margins for the bylation
trades and again this is in line with
asthma's recommendations reflecting the
sharp price rises in energy derivatives
on benchmarks I think how do you have
covered that very well and we work
together on achieving The Proposal you
have outlined and clearly also to
encourage when The Benchmark is in place
that it is used so that will impact
derivative markets as well I believe
that what we are proposing today on the
um energy or rather the Nexus between
the financial markets and energy will
make a real difference to energy
operators and to energy markets and in
the short to medium term that will help
alleviate pressure on consumers and
businesses who are experiencing energy
price Rises right now but at the same
time we're staying Vigilant when it
comes to financial instability thank you
thank you very much we have quite a few
people connected many people in the room
so I will start with batteries
and Carrick beat Rodriguez with the
Washington Post
um my first question is most of the
measures that you're presenting today
are meant to bring down the prices
during the refueling session but what
are the concrete measures that are going
to help to bring prices down this winter
and then my second question is that when
you were talking about during purchase
and solidarity measures you were
including the Eastern partnership and
Western bankans today president zelenski
said that 30 of the country
infrastructures power infrastructure
have been targeted by strikes so I was
wondering if there is concrete measures
that the U is preparing to support
Ukraine in the energy sector in
particular and warranty supply thank you
voila
um what Ukraine is concerned
indeed we are closely interconnected for
example with the electricity grid you
might recall that in February
towards the end of the February
um Ukraine decided to decouple from the
Russian grid
and we had planned to couple them to our
grid in two years
of course the Russians didn't let them
back into the Russian grid so it took us
two weeks to connect them to the
European grid and we had uh two or three
weeks ago a situation where they were
actively exporting electricity towards
the European Union and this would bring
revenues to them by that example I just
want to show we are in this together and
we will stand by their side and we will
deal with uh whatever Putin tries
together with the Ukraine to fence that
off and to to make sure that they stay
interconnected with us and they have the
support from our side
when you are asking what are you doing
on the prices this winter
so first of all
um the the first elements that we've
done
common storage
very important to keep the prices
reasonable
um
the common saving very important to have
more energy efficiency but the element
that we are now putting on the table is
the market correction mechanism
so again to take out the speculation and
the volatility of the ttf market
benchmark
um that is normal representative
and this will have a taming effect on
the prices the gas prices that are
traded in the European Union so this is
something which could be immediately
effective uh the moment we have fleshed
out the proposal we are doing today but
perhaps currently
since the war started we have helped
Ukraine to repair the damaged
infrastructure we have done so via the
specific fund that was created in the
energy community and that delivers them
not their own financial support but also
necessary equipment because to repair
your Creeds and thermal power plants you
need also this specific equipment we
also supported them with a technical
help to
to restore the Laboratories for example
in the Chernobyl nuclear site where
Russians left with service
well consequences that all the
monitoring equipment was demolished and
and uh and we are also supporting
Ukraine via the EU civil protection
mechanism and due to the fact that
Ukraine and Moldova are both
synchronized our electricity Creed
um this helps them to stabilize their
their Creed on top of that with this
joint purchase mechanism we offer them
the possibility to to join us for buying
alternative gas supplies for the next
winter now president already mentioned
that for this winter our actions to
stabilize TGF that is a benchmark
against what many long-term contracts
also are linked is the tool that helps
us to avoid extreme price bikes thank
you
thank you go to the platform erini
can you hear me
yes
thank you Eric Madam president you have
just mentioned that we are strong when
we are together do you feel that the
leaders will be United and they are
going to be together on Yuko and do you
feel confident that an agreement on
energy measures to tackle high prices is
going to be reached thank you
yes I am confident because
um we have been working very intensively
with the member states in the last weeks
and with many of the minister from the
energy ministers Council
and therefore what I see is much more
convergence on the question that we have
to tackle so a broad support on the
pooling of demand aggregation of demand
and Joint purchasing
by now broad support what the savings
and Energy Efficiency is concerned
because leaders see that it has a
positive effect
also support on uh the sharing or that
we have to establish rules how to share
in an extreme crisis situation this is
all going in the right direction now on
the price caps as you know it was
difficult at the beginning but the more
we go in depth the more we flesh out
what the possibilities uh are the more
we can convince member states to work
with that with us on that solution it
was first of all for us important to
stabilize the market so without the
preconditions that we have created and
we were all three referring to it would
not have been possible to come forward
now with these proposals
but now we are the time has come and now
I think it's important to really to move
on with a clear signal that we are
willing to be reliable Partners on the
market but not to any price eyes anymore
and last but not least
the topic that we need
to make sure that we have a Level
Playing Field in the European Union that
we have no fragmentation or Distortion
of the single market and even more
important that the competitiveness of
our industry and of our smes compared to
other Global players has to be protected
and supported is a common approach
so we all see that it is absolutely
necessary that we make sure that the
European Union despite the high energy
prices keeps it competitiveness on the
global market and therefore this is the
topic on repower EU and boosting repower
you where we're working on what we
expect from the European Council is
strategic guidance
that is what we want for this package
and then we have to flesh out the
details in the relevant Council
just a question on the new Benchmark is
one of the main things that you will use
to lower the prices if I understood
correctly correct me if I'm wrong you're
gonna prepare this for March or April
and you're gonna propose it to the
markets but you're not gonna force it
anyway to the market so it's up to the
markets to decide if they want to use
this match Mark or not
how confident I knew that this Benchmark
will work and the sellers and the buyers
will actually use your benchmark instead
of other benchmarks that are already on
the market thank you
well indeed so far long-term contracts
um are linked either with some
tasks related Benchmark the most popular
one is touchtickets or they are oil
linked and uh
if our agency Acer will receive
information daily basis of the volumes
and prices that LNG is in real life
traded then the EU level Benchmark is
more representative and this makes sense
to link your contacts then against this
representative Benchmark that doesn't
doesn't
have such a volatility
that DDF has has shown over the past
months
thank you very much I go back to the
platform I go to Reiner
Reynolds
so it's a follow-up question so that
means the new Benchmark will be applied
to Old contracts
by this proposal we are not opening the
existing long-term contracts the
existing long-term contracts are indexed
for example against DTF and in this
regard against this extreme volatility
helps a DTF cap that is useful for this
winter to avoid this extreme volatility
but by long-term contracts they are
negotiated by them private companies and
and this is a decision by them
um
both sides against what they are linking
their contracts
hello about the 40 million billion under
what uh conditions will will be given to
the states and when
to
uh the cohesion fund's flexibility
yeah so
um
cohesion funds
um they are still leftovers if I may
call it that way from 2014 to 2021
and here commissioner Ferreira is
working on flexibilizing parts of the
funds to make them available for member
states for example to tackle the energy
crisis and to invest These funds in
needs that come up because of the energy
crisis so these funds that originally
were purposed for other topics are
flexibilized to be given then to the
member states who still have funds
available
thank you go back to the platform and I
even thought to Annabelle
Jeremy and see me well I have a question
on the Iberian mechanism because this is
uh van delay and you say that it merits
to look deep into it and to look at how
to make it operational but I was
thinking that you the option was already
on the table since March at least since
uh for Monsters so I was wondering um if
this work why this work has not been
done until now and what is different now
so we have to look into it only now in
the mid end of October thank you we have
been looking at it intensively in the
last weeks and it was very helpful that
because of the specificities of the
Iberian Peninsula that it has been
introduced in the Iberian Peninsula so
we had kind of a field project where we
could get some experience and aggregate
data these data have a lot now
so we've gotten the data from Spain and
Portugal to model European potential
European models and they are as I said
it really merits to look deep into it
there are two topics that we have to
solve if we apply it on a European level
the one is
getting a bit technical but the model
says we will cap gas so that the price
of gas defines at a lower level the
price of electricity
but there is the real price of gas on
the market so you have to compensate
between the real price and the cap price
and this compensation takes place
through the the consumers who use gas
that works in the National environment
but if we put that on a European
environment you will have
a very a poorly balanced
support from gas consumers because you
have member states where there are a lot
of gas consumers and you have member
states where not so many gas consumers
because these member states have for
example Renewables and nuclear power
and therefore we have to sort out all of
them are benefiting from the cheaper
electricity
but in some member states more has to be
paid to have this cheap electricity than
in others therefore we have to sort out
how are we leveling this topic
and the second topic is basically the
same mechanism as we are well
interconnected with our friends and
neighbors UK Norway Switzerland Western
Balkan for example Eastern partnership
um this cheap electricity would also
flow there and we have to look at how
we're going to solve this question that
occur with that
um so get me right I think these
interconnections are very good so we're
lucky that we have them it's good to
have this energy Union this wide energy
Union but we have to tackle these two
questions before we can uh go further
with this model
you want to add something
maybe also one consideration was that in
Spring it was clear that we cannot allow
us the increase of gas consumption
now well we have been able to fill our
underground car storage but it still
doesn't mean that we have gas available
in abundance so whatever we will propose
it has to be aligned with a saving
obligation we cannot create higher
demand for gas
that I mean this whole you're right you
were asking also uh why now and not in
spring in Spring the ground was not at
all prepared we had empty and not very
nicely filled storages you might recall
that gasprom had under delivered
intentionally of course as we know today
so their storages were basically empty
we had no storage field for the winter
we had no infrastructure for common
purchasing or pooling or common saving
we did not have the element of the win
for profit but now we have a much better
bolster of fundament on which basis on
which we can start now with for example
cupping elements because we contain the
risks because we have prepared for this
winter
thank you yes I'm not
evidently from Europe diplomatic Madam
president you said that now there is a
massive switch to LNG uh so it means
that there will be also much more of
Maritime transport which already is
pretty polluting wouldn't it compromise
the climate goals of the European Union
how it will impact uh this very
important dossier of yours
this is a very important and a constant
challenge that while fencing of the
knock-on effects on fossil fuel energy
in our Union the knock-on effects of the
world we have to keep track with the
transformation into Renewables also
because it's not only good for our
climate but because these renewable
energies are homegrown and they make us
independent
it's good that we see today that as I
said initially the deployment and the
deliveries of renewable energy is at a
record high
right now this year in the European
Union so it's good that this is
increasing but we have to do more
um our Focus must be now but also in the
mid and in the long term on deploying
Renewables and therefore repower EU is
also so important because this puts the
focus on cross-border projects for
Renewables for the grid for example
infrastructure that is necessary so yes
it is a challenge we have to secure uh
today for this winter and for the next
winter
um the delivery of gas that are
necessary but at the same time we have
to keep trap and track on developing the
European green deal reducing the fossil
fuels and increasing the Renewables
thank you I go back to the platform
um I have Anna Matos
hello can you hear me
and Michael's nervous for Portuguese
agency loser first of all follow up with
my colleagues a question regarding the
bearing mechanism
um because in the document the
commission said there are a couple of
risks
um about extending this to the whole EU
so I'd like to understand which type of
risks are we talking about and thinking
into account that the country has had to
notify the commission about their
efforts on the reduction of the demand
on gas until mid-october I wonder if the
commission can already provide some
figures on this matter thank you
which yeah we have received the the
latest
um saving data from uh from member
states and uh and uh as president
mentioned in her introductory remarks um
September compared to the September last
year the demand reduction has been 15 to
your level of course different member
states have achieved different savings
targets
thank you very much my name is Noemi
nameity and I'm from MTV a Hungary
according to a price cup or price limit
critics or experts say that this could
lead to exporters Turning towards other
markets rather than the EU and also
could be interpreted as in other
assumptions towards Russia that could
get a hard answer did the commission
consider the um possibility of Russia
suspending gas flowing to the EU this
winter and what would be the effects of
of such a such an answer
so Russia has proven in the last eight
months that it's completely unreliable
and that it is deliberately
um cutting the gas flows to the European
Union that's no more honoring any kind
of its pipeline contracts therefore you
cannot count on Russia and we have to
take our decisions in an independent
manner
that is for us a principle
thank you very much this brings us to
the end of today's press conference
married
important addition which I neglected to
um bring to your attention uh while we
know that it is Russia that is the
problem in terms of Supply we're also
concerned to carefully look at if there
is speculative activity or any activity
that may need further attention now we
don't believe that speculation is
significant however in order to really
verify that with figures we've asked the
energy regulator and the financial
markets regulator to coordinate all of
their work to share information so that
we can base our assessments on good
analysis and I think that's hugely
important particularly in times of huge
uncertainty and particularly when it
reflects in very considerable price
increases so apologies I didn't bring
that to your attention earlier thank you
thank you very much as I was saying this
brings us to the end of our press
conference but please stay with us we
don't have a second press conference on
a decision or proposals made today by
the commission on critical
infrastructure protection thank you
[Music]